- [N.G.] While we would like to think
that we can predict people's behavior,
we can't always do that.
People behave in unexpected ways.
They do things that are
unthinkable and unimaginable.
And thus the question becomes
"How do you understand that?",
"How do you dissect behavior?"
- [Narrator] The Hulu
original series Chance
paints the portrait of a
forensic neuropsychiatrist
who embarks on his own dark journey.
We take a closer look at the new thriller
with the help of a real-life
neuropsychologist.
(suspenseful music)
(lamp clicks)
- My name is Doctor N.G. Berrill.
I'm a forensic neuropsychologist
and essentially I focus on
decoding the puzzle of human behavior.
Quite often we meet people
who function according to societal norms
and slowly over time, they
deteriorate in some way,
where they make choices which are peculiar
or self-destructive.
- [Hugh] Eldon Chance is a 55 year-old,
right-handed neuropsychiatrist.
Of late, he is increasingly aware
of a mental state he finds
to be dark and unstable.
- And those people are interesting
because their life doesn't follow a path
that's easily predicted and understood.
Everyone has a story.
They got to be where they are
owing to a host of factors.
- I spend my days in the company
of those mutilated by life.
- As a clinical neuropsychologist,
the areas of the brain
that are of most importance
would be the limbic system
and prefrontal cortex,
or the prefrontal lobe.
The limbic system regulates
human emotion, affective memory,
our capacity to become
angry, even aggressive.
So, for example, if we
have a perceived threat,
that may activate the limbic system.
(grunting)
Now it's the prefrontal area
that perceive this activation
and then help us to determine
how we wanna proceed.
If the prefrontal lobes
are not working properly,
you can have a lot of trouble.
There can be really a bad situation.
(cars honking)
- [Eldon] Since his
discharge, the patient admits
to both visual and
olfactory hallucinations.
- When we look at ourselves,
we always have explanations
and rationalizations for why we
don't behave as we should have.
People don't always behave rationally,
and they're not always responsible.
- Do you really still not see
what dangerous ground this is?
Or is that what you like about it?
- Certainly there are
a number of challenges
in doing forensic neuropsychology
or forensic psychology.
Sometimes we put ourselves in situations,
which there is some potential
risk or some potential danger.
Maybe that's what makes it
a little exciting as well,
the unpredictable nature of it all.
(lamp clicks)